[Musica]
ma benvenuti alla nuova edizione del
leccio concari buzz o mio dio ce
l'abbiamo fatta abbiamo un nuovo studio
che circa come potete vedere lo sfondo è
rimasto più o meno sempre lo stesso ma
molto più grande a mo di finestrone ed a
questa parte abbiamo una piccola parete
per staccare un pochino i colori con due
quadretti attaccati sicuramente voi
occhi d'aquila avrete notato che questo
quadretto qui e hitler non spaventatevi
queste sono due splendide illustrazioni
di jacovitti e finalmente posso anche
muovermi con la sedia questo è proprio
il futuro beh allora come state coeva
avete passato bene questi mesi mia
assenza e o discretamente bene grazie
per avermelo chiesto
certo ho ricevuto una marea di merda per
il penultimo video che ho caricato sul
canale no che dobbiamo fare ebbene sì
quel video è stato o frainteso o da
parte mia non c'è stata una giusta
spiegazione e per iniziare alla
grandissima questa nuova edizione dello
show insieme
mi piacerebbe ripartire proprio da quel
punto dopo che ho cercato di spiegare
che lo youtube al di fuori della
piattaforma al di fuori di internet
venga visto come un pagliaccio
nullafacente molti colleghi molti
youtubers giustamente si sono ricordati
di avere una scopa in casa e se la sono
messa nel culo non nel senso che
giustamente si sono un po stizziti da
quelle parole perché nel marasma di
centinaia di migliaia di video che
compongono youtube italia ovviamente
qualche artista effettivamente c'è ma
parlare bene di qualcuno non fa visual
fare flame fa visual anche involontario
manette queste stronzate qui quello che
era il mio obiettivo con quel video e
cercare di umanizzare noi cercare di
appiattire questa differenza di fama che
c'è tra il pubblico lo youtube come mio
solito esasperandone un pochino il
concetto per amore dell'intrattenimento
non l'ho fatto certo per far scoppiare
la terza guerra mondiale nei commenti il
messaggio
devo far trasparire con quei titoli era
proprio siamo umani anche noi è una
delle paure più materiali dell'essere
umano è quella di non riuscire ad avere
abbastanza soldi per vivere e qui mi
ricollego all'argomento e dal fatto che
con youtube questa certezza non c'è o
almeno non per tutti perché sfatiamo un
mito non tutti youtuber guadagnano
20mila euro al mese
soprattutto se non fai un video per due
mesi vero cari vero questo problema a
volte dipende dalla giornata si
trasforma in un macigno tipo obelix che
ti si arrampica sulla schiena e non va
più via
e per farvi capire meglio questo
concetto vorrei parlarvi di un dvd il
fidanzato ideale ma qua come gli eau
topi proprio perché non guadagni 20mila
euro al mese
ti sei rimesso a fare recensioni di film
piccolo pezzettino di stronzo no questo
non è un film questo questo e questo dvd
questo questo è una pessima idea
questo dvd potrebbe tranquillamente
vincere il premio come peggior cosa da
fare quando la fama inizia a svanire
innanzitutto il protagonista che è beppe
convertini il signor beppe è un attore
italiano che dopo aver fatto svariati
ruoli minori è finito a fare tra il 2000
e il 2003
la soap opera vivere
comunque dopo la chiusura di vivere devi
ovviamente cercarti qualcos'altro da
fare e aggrappandosi con i pugni e con i
denti a quella fama che vivere ti ha
dato deve usarla per sopravvivere
perdonate il gioco di parole e quindi
magari un giorno si è sdraiato sul
divano di casa tua e devi contattato da
una persona che ti dice ma tu sei il
signor beppe quello di vivere
lei è bello signor beppe è bello le
casalinghe lo adorano
che ne direbbe di fare qualcos'altro
insieme tipo video sia per cada
tralasciando che questo dvd è stato
prodotto dalla eagle pictures
ipotizzo che la finanza avesse bussato
alle loro porte che avessero bisogno di
soldi in quel 2004 e quel signore che al
telefono ha chiamato il signor beppe a
casa sua quel giorno non è altro che
guido bagatta ma guido bagatta quello di
quello di real tipico equa il guido
bagatta dio mio se quei guido bagatta
prima di farvi vedere in cosa consiste
il fidanzato ideale vorrei leggervi
giusto due righe di sinossi con il
fidanzato ideale tutte potranno avere a
disposizione il loro principe azzurro
virtuale
ogni volta che vorranno un ora di
divertimento il romanticismo per le
ragazze di tutte le età e come non
comprare un dvd che c'ha pure degli
errori grammaticali nella sinossi e ora
il contenuto del dvd dunque come abbiamo
detto prima il signor convertini dopo
aver fatto vivere aveva ancora un sacco
di fan un sacco di casalinghe si
strappavano i capelli alla vista della
sua brillante ed immensa bellezza
io non posso giudicare la bellezza di un
altro uomo perché oi testicoli però sono
abbastanza convinto che a livello
generale la bellezza di quest'uomo ci
sia nulla da dire
e quindi hanno cercato di dt lucrarci
sopra come giusto che sia
e quindi mi accingo a inserire il dvd
dentro il lettore dvd del mio portatile
e questo è quello che vedo no no no no
no amore
torna subito a letto stamattina che ho
preparato la colazione e voi di tutela
costituita e stata una settimana
stressante e oggi deve iniziare almeno
ecco questo sketch che avete appena
visto è il contenuto del dvd è uno dei
molteplici sketch che compongono il
tutto monete uno dietro l'altro senza
una trama è l'unico collegamento che
unisce il tutto è che lui è il fidanzato
di una ragazza che non esiste o meglio
la ragazza siamo noi che stiamo
guardando lui che ci parla che ne dici
se le mattine andiamo a fare shopping
ti dirò di più che ne dici se ne va a
fare shopping con questa carta di
credito e basta non c'è nient'altro
e tra l'altro il dvd ha mentito perché
dietro c'è scritto un ora di
divertimento e romanticismo per le
ragazze di tutte le età ma se noi
togliamo il backstage e gli errori dal
dvd e prendiamo solo questa parte
centrale che è il fulcro di un ragazzo
ideale dura poco meno di venti minuti
hanno praticamente preso uno famoso
l'hanno messo in dei set preassemblati
di mondo convenienza e gli hanno fatto
dire le cose più banali mi dovete
credere le cose più blande proprio né le
robacce che condividono le dodicenni su
facebook perché non sanno ancora come
funziona il mondo quelle cose lì ho
capito sono fatti miei
non voglio immischiarmi dei segreti tori
delle famiglie sono sicurissimo che ci
sarà qualche ragazzo qualche donna che
apprezzerà avere la compagnia di un uomo
del genere al proprio fianco però per
noi uomini ve lo posso assicurare vedere
e sentire delle cose del genere per 20
minuti e niente de mi tocca prendere un
cacciavite svit armi [ __ ] e buttarli
nell'umido nel dubbio facciamo così se
la yeti sul letto rilassa e aspetta che
ti porti qualcosa di caldo vedo se
abbiamo anche qualche medicina e casi
anche se la miglior medicina
ti prego non dirlo ti prego non dirlo
non devi dirlo perché devi dirlo ti
prego non dirlo sono senz'altro delle
coccole ottimo quindi quale uso quello
di destro quello di sinistra non capisco
perché ti ostini a mettere le lenti a
contatto anche con gli occhiali
semplicamente da morire
la mia talpa sensi la mia talpa sexy
mioddio signor beppe convertini mi
scriva alla mail di lavoro per dirmi
come fa una talpa ad essere sexy
la tris penale ma è che c'era tutto il
tuo lavoro avevo salvato una copia
dell'atto relazione su questo dischetto
ha forse ho sbagliato a dir la data
forse è del 1992 questo dvd
no no è del 2004 lo conferma anche
wikipedia e allora perché salvi i file
in un distretto nel 2004 e perché lo
chiami distetto altro vorrei fare un
salutone speciale al montatore che ha
montato quel dvd lì per chiedergli
perché le transizioni a fischio perché
venissero l'inizio però provare un po di
dispiacere per il signor convertini che
comunque ha lavorato anche dopo e ha
lavorato prima ovviamente a teatro e in
televisione per l'amor di dio io ho
parlato di questo dvd perché perché io
non voglio finire a fare una cosa del
genere
non voglio finire a fare il fidanzato
ideale o una cosa simile non voglio
finire ad essere usato da altre persone
semplicemente per la mia fama per poter
far lavorare qualcuno perché questo dvd
è la prova vivente che a volte le cose
si fanno soltanto per poter far lavorare
qualcuno e questo è quanto questo è il
messaggio che avrei voluto far passare
anche l'altra volta ma ovviamente ho
fatto un video completamente diverso e
non è uscito del tutto questo messaggio
e comunque se dovessi arrivare a toccare
il fondo del barile e fossi costretto a
fare una cosa come il fidanzato ideale
soltanto per lavorare a secondo me
uscirebbe in modo completamente diverso
ciao dopo il grande successo di un
fidanzato ideale
ho pensato di fare la mia versione di
questo dvd il fidanzato di nico dove
potrò dirvi tutte quelle cose che
nessuno nessuno vi ha mai detto ma ti
ricordi quando ci siamo visti per la
prima volta in quella discoteca quando
io ti dissi tutte quelle splendide cose
per farti innamorare di me beh non è
vero niente
gli ho detto quelle cose soltanto per
poter mettere il mio gigantesco in mezzo
alle due gigantesche per dentro
[Musica]
sto per andare al lavoro perché non ci
divertiamo un pochino prima e poi vai a
prepararmi il pranzo perché ancora non
mi hai preparato da portare al lavoro
pista senza